ينضم الينا من اربيل لور صبر الحارس
السابق للمنتخب العراقي يسعد صباحك يا نور
شكرا على تواجدك معانا تشرح لنا ما الذي
حصل شو صار يعني ليش التنمر تحديدا يا نور
كيف شفت انت هذا التنمر
صباح الخير عليكم صباح الخير على كل
المشاهدين العربيه اكيد وصباح الخير على
الجميع
الحقيقه انا يعني من الشخصيات او من الناس
اللي
متفهم للوضع وان كنت حزين لطريقه التعامل
مع الصوره وهو ليس بالجديد بالنسبه لي انه
انا انزل صور مع اولادي بشكل مستمر احتفل
بهم واحتفي بيهم في كل نجاح يقدموه
لانفسهم بالتالي يعني هذا انا اشعر بفخر
كبير واتعرض لفتره والاخرى لامور تخص خاصه
لما يكون بناتي بالصوره يعني اولادي
ماكو عليها مشكله لكن لما يكون الموضوع
يخص البنت هنا المساله يعني مختلفه يمكن
اكو جزء انا فرحان بيه وسعيد هو طريقه
تعامل الناس او رده فعل الناس هذا يمكن
يفتح باب
للتعامل اخر مع المراه مع البنت يعني
بالتحديد لانه احنا بالفتره الماضيه ولا
لا يزال انه المراه والبنت يعني تتعرض
دائما لكثير من الاعتداءات بالتحرشات اذا
كانت على المستوى الشارع على مستوى الاهل
منع ورفض دائما البنت دائما
انت اليوم تصف حاله يعاني منها الكثيرون
اليوم في المجتمعات خصوصا من جراء تعليقات
سوشيال ميديا بس كمان انا اسمح لي شخصيا
ارحب بوجودك معنا في برنامج صباح العربيه
على شاشه العربيه اولا وايضا نور كمان شو
تفسيرك لهذه الحاله على السوشيال ميديا عم
نلاقي جيوش الكترونيه عم بلاقي اشخاص
يقومون ويتجراون وقاحه على نشر تعليقات
موسيقى واعطاء رايهم وهم اصلا مختبئين فوق
الشاشه وفوق
نعاني يعني بصراحه بصريح العباره احنا
نعاني معاناه كبيره مع الناس يعني حتى
واحنا مثلا خلينا نقول نسوي عملنا الخاص
اعلاناتنا الخاصه شغل اي شيء هناك معترضين
لكل شيء وكانه العمليه هي عباره عن يجب
انه انتقد اي قضيه مهما تكون بدون ما يعرف
المحتوى الحقيقي بدون ما يعرف في العبره
من هذا الفيديو او الصوره او الحكمه اللي
تنزل عن طريق السوشيال ميديا اعتقد
المشكله الحقيقيه هو عدم وجود الرقابه
خاصه احنا بالعراق عندنا مشكله بعدم وجود
الرقابه على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي لان
الموضوع بالحقيقه لما يتحول يعني يصير
متطرف يعني ويصير ديني وهذه الان تلعب
بعقول الشباب هذه مساله جدا خطيره يعني
يعني
احنا نعاني منها بشكل كبير لكن انا اعتقد
ايضا على عاتق المعنيين المسؤولين انه
يكون هناك رقابه مثل باقي دول الخليج هناك
رقابه على كل كلمه تكتب لانه احنا بصراحه
نتعرض الى تهديد ولا نتعرض حتى الى اسب
وشتم باللي عوائلنا بشتى الوسائل
اعتقد الشباب الرئيسي هو غياب الرقابه طيب
نور انت حجبت كل التعليقات على صورتك في
انستجرام ماذا تقول عبر شاشه العربيه لكل
المتنمرين
والله انا مسحتها على الفيسبوك ما كنت
اتخيل انه لانه الموضوع اخذ اكثر من حجمه
الطبيعي بس مساحه الصوره على الفيسبوك
وبالتالي ما قلت ندمت لكن تسرعت انهم
مساحتها لانه انا كنت خايف على بنتي فقط
لا اكثر انا ما اخاف من احد كل وقتي يعني
تعاملت مع نفسي ومع عائلتي انه دائما
متعودين على هذه الضغوطات التعليقات
اسمه الحقيقي هو الشخص الجمال والذي يبث
سمومه وامراض النفسيه الى العالم والى
المستخدمين مع ذلك انا اراعي شارع مشاعر
اولادي والقريبين فحبيت انه اخفي لكن تبقى
الصوره مثل ما هي وانا ان شاء الله على
طول اولادك ويحفظ لك بناتك شوفوا حالهم
فيك نور بس في كمان شغله هيك نقطه صغيره
انه احيانا بيقولوا انه المشهور او
المعروف خصوصا اذا انت حارس سابه للمنتخب
العراقي ومشهور رياضيا ومعروف في العراق
بقولوا لك انه لازم تكون اصلا متجاهل
ودائما في تصويب سهام على كثير من الناس
مثلا رؤساء دول يطالهم مسبات وتعليقات
موسيقى فبالتالي عليك ان تتحمل انت كيف
بترد على هاي النظريه
انا اقول انه اني بشر حالي حال الجميع
عندي مشاعر وعندي احاسيس واتاثر في بعض
الاوقات افرح واحزن بشر طبيعي لو كنت مو
طبيعي ممكن انا اكون مثل لو كنت حديد على
اللي اشوفه واللي يشوفوه اكيد اللي مثلي
يعني انا اشوفها صعبه جدا في بعض الاوقات
انا ما اتردد بالرد بقسوه على على البعض
لانه اكو كلمات بصراحه انت تعرفين واللي
يشوفني يعرف انه صعب يعني تجاوقات انه
يكون احنا يعني داخلي مقهور جدا لاجيب انه
ارد يجب انه اطلع يجب يعني اوضح لهذا
الشخص انه انت ما تقوله هذا هذا خطا كبير
وتجاوز علينا فلا انا ما اشوف انه يجب انه
يتجاهل ممكن في بعض الاوقات لكن مو كل
الوقت لانه بصراحه صار تمادي بهذه المساله
نور
نعم انا فقط يعني ساختم معك واقول لك يبقى
الاب اوفى حبيب لابنته ولو احب هالعالم